put in check one two three four five six
are you get out there everybody good
Mic Check one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten
Mic Check one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten
microphone check one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten
microphone check one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten we're good
microphone check one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten
microphone check you good
I now check one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten
and now check one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten
announced check one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten and now check
one two
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well thank you very much please great
honor sweltering day but I do want to
thank you all for being here as we
proudly launched the White House
Hispanic prosperity initiative for
exciting exciting thank you with this
very exciting new effort we will deliver
a future of greater promise opportunity
and freedom for nations really it's a
treasure you are a treasure
the Hispanic Americans and the Hispanic
American community is a treasure thank
you we're thrilled to be joined today by
Secretary of Education Betsy DeVos Thank
You Betsy Thank You Secretary of
Commerce Wilbur Ross Thank You /
Secretary of Housing and Urban
Development Ben Carson thank you Ben
small business administrator Jovita
Thank You Jovita and Representative Mike
Garcia thank you thank you
congratulations Mike that was a big win
biggest in 22 years they say first time
in 22 years that's a good one well you
got something special going right thank
you my great job yesterday I was
delighted to host my friend president
Lopez Obrador
Mexico here in the White House and
affirmed the close and continued
friendship between the United States and
Mexico it's never been better the
executive order I will sign in a few
moments will expand our efforts across
all federal government to deliver
educational and economic opportunity for
Hispanic Americans
at the heart of our strategy to create a
prosperous future for every hispanic
american as well as all americans is a
great family of education we are going
to have a tremendous program and we have
and you know we're a believer in choice
choice the other folks don't believe in
choice and choice is a great civil
rights issue and maybe the great one of
our times i'm going to fight to ensure
that every hispanic american parent has
the freedom and the right to send your
child to the public private charter
faith-based magnet home
or independent school of your choice and
school choice is a incredible issue in
many ways it's a political issue I agree
most people agree with us the smart ones
definitely agree with us but it's also a
moral issue and it really is a
fundamental issue of civil rights
no American students should ever be
trapped in a failing government school
which has happened so often for so many
years it's one of the problems you see
when you see these cities going up in
flame one of the most successful
educational models is the charter school
which has been under unceasing attack
from the radical left charter schools
charter schools have been incredible but
they're under attack and you know why
they're under attack more than 1 million
Hispanic American children currently
attend charter schools and nearly 1 in 3
charter school students is Hispanic
American I'm proud that under my
administration we've delivered 1.5
billion dollars for public charter
schools that's a record
as long as I'm president I will never
let your charter schools be taken away
from you be taken down I will never let
you down I will never let
hispanic-american or any American down
that I can tell you under leadership the
Hispanic American high school graduation
rate has reached an all-time high in the
history of our country and the dropout
rate has reached an all-time low in the
history of our country
we've also delivered a 1 billion dollar
grant for minority serving institutions
including Hispanic serving institutions
of higher learning our new Hispanic
prosperity initiative will also expand
access to trade school something that's
been really badly missing trade schools
so important work based learning and
vocational education so important and
vocational when I was young growing up I
used to see vocational school Edinson
vocational school that meant people with
a great talent but a talent different
than history and math and other things
but they had the same talent or far
greater than many of the a student's
have studied under the things vocational
school great people great talent and
they do very well they do very well
through our pledge to the American
worker we've already made available 16
million apprenticeships and training
opportunities for the jobs of tomorrow
to bring jobs and prosperity to our most
distressed communities we created nearly
9,000 opportunity zones that's been a
great success a tremendous Tim Scott of
South Carolina's helped me some way
which have already brought nearly 100
billion dollars in investment to
neighborhoods where millions of Hispanic
Americans live and you see it so many of
you already today and speaking with you
you said what a difference that made
before the plague from China came in you
know what that is that's the China virus
before it came in and hit us we achieved
the lowest hispanic american
unemployment rate and the lowest poverty
rate ever recorded history of our
country ever recorded and we're getting
back very quickly we achieved the
highest ever incomes for Hispanic
Americans and many other American groups
and communities we built the greatest
economy in history not only for our
country but for the world we were number
one by far China had the worst year in
67 years they weren't happy with what
was going they were going in the wrong
direction and then the plague came in
but together we will do it again and we
will do it very quickly and we're
already doing it we will achieve a swift
full and complete recovery for Hispanic
Americans and the Hispanic American
community and we're doing it very very
rapidly our strategy focuses on
sheltering the most vulnerable including
older Americans and nursing home
residents while allowing those at lower
risks such as young and healthy children
in many cases the the immune system is
so powerful so strong but the younger
the healthy to safely return to working
to school we have to open our schools
open our schools stop this nonsense we
open our schools Germany Norway so many
countries right now they're open the
schools are open and they're doing just
fine and they're opening in the fall so
we have to get our schools open Denmark
Sweden we have to get our schools open
and stop this political nonsense and
it's only political nonsense it's
politics they don't want to open because
they think it will help them on November
3rd I think it's going to hurt them on
November 3rd open your schools at the
same time we're unleashing the
scientific brilliance of our people we
have multiple effective therapies in use
already with more being developed and
you have
see some of them the results are looking
incredible and we were in track to
produce a vaccine in record time and
very very soon it's going to be
announced I believe very very soon so we
have therapies and we have vaccines
utilizing these advances and the skill
of our doctors and nurses we have
dramatically reduced mortality rates we
have among the lowest mortality rate
anywhere in the world we've done a great
job whether it's ventilators or anything
you want to look at testing we test so
many people that we have more cases
everybody says we have so many cases
that's because we test so many people up
to approximately 40 million tests going
up to 45 very quickly so we have tests
other countries don't do tests like we
do so we show cases other countries
don't show cases but what we do have is
we have perhaps the lowest but among the
lowest but perhaps the lowest mortality
rate death rate anywhere in the world
and that's a tremendous sign as to what
we're doing and what our doctors have
learned and the kind of things that
we're using it's been an it's an
incredible number statistically an
incredible number a policy of never
ending lockdowns month after month would
ultimately do more harm than good to
public health and so bad for our
children as a result it really is more
loss of life we can't do that we have to
get back down we did it right we save
millions of lives by what we did we shut
it down we save millions of lives I put
a ban on China heavily infected I put a
ban on Europe very early both of them
very early we save millions of lives now
it's time to get back to work
a lot of people were against those bands
and now they admit most of those same
people admit that band was the greatest
thing saved so many lives crucially we
realized that the health of a nation's
economy is fundamental to the health of
its people in the last two months we
have begun the fastest economic comeback
in history including an increase in
Hispanic American employment of more
than 2.1 million
it's a record the Hispanic prosperity
initiative will help build on this
program I will be naming a leader of
incredible vision former lieutenant
governor of New Mexico
John Sanchez and I know he's here John
I'd love to have you come up and say a
few words please
[Applause]
Thank You mr. president
what an honor it is to be here with you
and everybody else here in our nation's
capitol
let me say from a young boy who grew up
in absolute poverty the youngest of
eight kids with a single mother I
understand what it is for the challenges
facing all families but especially
Hispanic families in this country but
because of her leadership through
personal responsibility stay in school
get a good education
we have lived the American dream as a
young boy I used to go and search for
cardboard boxes out of the trash cans of
grocery stores because we didn't have
the souls mr. president on our shoes we
would hope and pray they wouldn't rain
so the cardboard wouldn't melt on our
way to school here now almost 50 years
later I stand next to the most powerful
man in the world and the most powerful
city in the world at the White House
with all of you fine folks today I have
lived the American dream I look at my
brand-new black shoes that's the
American dream mr. president your
readership when it comes to job creation
education reform choice when it comes to
education will allow this country to
fulfill its American dream I'm honored
to be here with you mr. president
your great leadership making America
great we stand with you will keep
America great under your leadership god
bless you thank you very much
very much going on I'll also be
appointing the CEO and president of Goya
foods Bob you none way please good
afternoon mr. president good afternoon
everyone it's such an honor and such a
blessing to be here in the greatest
country in the world the most prosperous
country in the world and we continue to
grow and that's what we're here to do
today our company was founded in 1936 by
my grandfather who left Spain and only
18 years old did not know where he was
heading but it was heading and looking
for opportunity and prosperity and he
found it in this great country today our
company is a multi-billion dollar
company with thousands of employees and
with facilities all around the globe we
have a tremendous group of what we call
like a time familia Goya the Goya family
the great Koya family and these are
people I told the president earlier we
haven't gone back to work we never
stopped working because when I asked our
group our family this is going to be a
tough thing they said look Bob if we
don't do it nobody will and they stood
up and they worked and we continued to
work day and night to provide
much-needed food and nutrition to this
country today it gives me great honor
and by the way we're all truly blessed
at the same time to have a leader like
President Trump who was a builder and
that's what my grandfather did he came
to this country to build to grow to
prosper and so we have an incredible
builder and we pray we pray for our
leadership our president and we pray for
our country that we will continue to
prosper and and to grow
today I have an announcement to make
that the gun familia Goya wanted to
share with all of you there's a great
need today in food banks around the
country food is being depleted hopefully
as the summer ends we have new crops
coming forward but right now there's
there is a shortage so our employees and
some partners we have in the industry
wanted to donate 1 million cans of
goryeo chickpeas and a million pounds of
food these are all products made in the
United States steal from the United
States steal Silvan containers produces
rice mill in Arkansas donating food our
farmers and again all of our products a
lot of our products are grown here in
the United States made in America and
we're very proud to give back to this
nation to the food banks whit's are
gonna be needing some of that important
food something that we do all year but
in particular at this special time we
wanted to make that gift so god bless
you all we hope that we continue to
prosper and grow in this great country
and give thanks to God thank you very
much thank you Bob thank you very nice
we're all so grateful to be joined by
future commission members standing
behind me Mario Rodriguez Steve Cortez
Lourdes Aguirre Hosea went as Cassandra
Garcia Mead Chris Garcia hey soos
Marquez David Olli Rehn sua Alfredo
Ortiz thank you all very much for being
here great great group of people who
just had a fantastic meeting Hispanic
Americans are cherished members of our
national family there have been an
integral part of building this country
throughout all of American history over
generations Hispanic Americans
started countless small businesses
inspired our communities and served our
country in every way imaginable as
police officers service members Border
Patrol agents pastors teachers and
business leaders they're incredible
now Hispanic Americans are watching as
the cities they help build the
communities they help police the
businesses they created and the dreams
they pursued are being threatened by an
extreme movement that wants to tear
everything down at the center of this
movement is an aggressive effort to
defund the police if you can even
believe that to fund the police think
about that so sad said think these
people are crazy they are crazy
which would inflict great harm on our
hard-working Latino communities great
great harm many immigrants came to the
United States in order to leave
countries where the rule of law had been
eroded and they don't want those same
conditions to be replicated here they
don't want them back they know what it
is firsthand they know what happens when
the police cannot protect the innocent
when the rule of law is destroyed when
justice becomes an instrument of
vengeance Hispanic Americans they know
they're hardworking Patriots who support
our police protect our communities and
believe strongly in the rule of law I
will stand arm in arm with the Hispanic
community to ensure that every child in
America can grow up in safety security
dignity and in peace we believe that the
timeless principles of the Declaration
of Independence and the US Constitution
are all shared and they have to be
shared in a big beautiful heritage of
all Americans whether you're a
first-generation American or a
fifth-generation American this is your
home American history is your history
it's about you it's about your family
it's about our country and the American
Dream belongs
coolly to you American heroes inspire us
all and their legacy Falls to all of us
to cherish and to protect and to revere
every American no matter your background
is entitled to a government that puts
your needs and your families first
Americans of all walks of life are
united by the same noble ideas and the
same fundamental designs for good
schools strong families safe communities
and abundant opportunity and I will not
rest until we have delivered this future
for every community not only the
Hispanic community which is doing so
well but every community in our land
together we will write the next great
chapter of the American adventure and we
will defend the greatness of America for
your children for your children's
children and for generations to come
before signing this executive order
which is such an important executive
order I'd like to invite secretary
divorcé to come up and say a few words
followed by administrator Carranza
please come up Betsy thank you thank you
so much mr. president for your
leadership on this initiative as you
have noted education opens the door to
prosperity and opportunity and Hispanic
students like all students need to have
the freedom and choice to find their
education fit mr. president you have led
in advancing opportunity for Hispanic
students by supporting Hispanic serving
higher ed institutions by expanding the
opportunities for charter schools by
expanding the DC Opportunity Scholarship
Program right here in the district and
there's still more to do
because all Hispanic students across our
country need to have the opportunity to
choose their right education fit they
need to have school choice we know this
is broadly supported by Hispanic
families 80 percent of them support
this notion of insuring their children
and their grandchildren have that
opportunity so Thank You mr. president
for your leadership in ensuring that all
Hispanic students have that chance at
the American dream thanks mr. president
[Applause]
I can't believe I blinked at you
president Thank You mr. president it's a
tremendous honor to be part of an
administration so dedicated to helping
Latino entrepreneurs this during this
extraordinary time in our country as the
daughter of first-generation
mexican-americans I know firsthand how
important opportunity is toward
promoting upward mobility and enabling
the American Dream creating
opportunities is the central goal behind
the president's new executive order
establishing the White House Hispanic
prosperity initiative designed to help
Hispanic Americans reach their dreams
through innovative education and career
pathways under your leadership mr.
president Latinos have been the
fastest-growing group of entrepreneurs
in the country and we want to see that
continue hola soy Kavita Carranza
I mean estado de Villa SBA es una noir
ser parte del cabinet a Dell
administration Trump que estar de cada
ayudar a los impresarios Latinos durante
estos temples difíciles communica de
Parys mexicanos Americanos sell no
importante que estén err oportunidades
para alcanzar el Sueno americano lameta
el presidente Truong Sa you dar a los
latinos alcanzar su sueños otra vez de
la educación y Nova Dora y Carreras por
eso es fundamental st or then he to be
to executive
but a nuestra comunidad la comunidad a
spanner Els LSB a moon amigo en La Casa
Blanca
Casa de Rica a nuestra comunidad este
Presidente es una persona FINA gracias
mic maybe you come up just and say a
real quick word cuz it's about you know
like setting records out here but come
on this man is such a big star now
California you win in California a lot
of Republicans winning in California
Mike I think please I hope so I think
it's the beginning of something great in
California personally mr. president
thank you for the honor of being here
today it's a it's a huge honor to be
here with my Hispanic brothers and
sisters leaders in your communities
leaders in your respective businesses I
am the American dream I am a first
generation American my dad immigrated
here from Mexico when he was nine years
old
I had the opportunity to serve my
country in the US Navy flying the the
most powerful strike fighter jets in the
world the f-18 off the aircraft carriers
in combat operations and now I'm sitting
here as a member of Congress on the on
the lawn of the White House so I'd like
to just echo the president's comments
that now is the time where we need to
unite as Americans and really realize
what this fight is all about it's about
freedom it's about liberties it's about
fighting like it's 1776 all over again
that's how real this fight is so I'm
proud to be here I'm proud to be serving
my country again at this most critical
time in our nation's history and mr.
president thank you for your leadership
brothers and sisters thank you for being
here today huge honor thank you
ben Carson please come up just for a
minute say a few words Ben you've done
such a great job thank you very much
Thank You mr. president and thank you
all for being here today you know it's
so important the emphasis that you have
placed on opportunity and you asked the
White House Counsel an opportunity
revitalization to look at those
communities that were particularly
effective in the coab at 19 and we
looked at that and not just the fact
that there was more hypertension and
diabetes obesity asthma but to look
another layer underneath that and to
deal with that and that's what we're
doing under your leadership and you know
every single person in our society is
worth saving we only have 330 million
people it sounds like a lot but it's a
quarter of what China has a quarter of
what India has and we're gonna have to
compete with them in the future so we
need to develop all of our people and
your emphasis on education and
educational choice will be the thing
that really distinguishes and liberates
our people so thank you mr. president
so now I'm gonna go and sign a very
important document one that we've been
working on for a long time and I just
want to congratulate the Hispanic
American community incredible people
thank you very much and God bless you
all god bless america thank you very
much
[Applause]
mr. president will you take some
questions from us
you